bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de michael à metz bonjour bonjour nous
voici partis pour un tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec d'abord
cette semaine la polémique créée par
laurent wauquiez autour du rsa
le ministre des affaires européennes
évoque le cancer des dérivés de
l'assistanat recadrage de matignon et de
l'elysée qui rappelle les mérites du
système
quelle mouche a donc piqué le ministre
le gouvernement s'est aussi intéressée
cette semaine aux plus riches avec la
réforme de la fiscalité du patrimoine en
conseil des ministres suppression du
bouclier fiscal mais aussi à les jours
de l'impôt sur la fortune tout sera
examiné au jour par les deux assemblées
et pendant que la majorité se déchire
autour du rsa les socialistes se trouve
un sujet de belle unanimité les
célébrations du 10 mai 30 ans après
l'accession au pouvoir de françois
mitterrand
journée portes ouvertes à solférino avec
pour slogan d'une victoire à l'autre
allusion bien sûr à 2012 les pour
commenter toute cette actualité vincent
peillon bonjour vous êtes notre invité
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen
vous comptez aussi parmi les dirigeants
très influent du parti socialiste vous
avez d'ailleurs participé amplement
l'élaboration du projet pour 2012
ce que l'on sait peut être un petit peu
moins de vous c'est que vous êtes agrégé
et docteur en philosophie et c'est vrai
que c'est une chose qui peut servir le
philosophe il fallait l'être sans doute
dans vos rapports avec ségolène royal
vous est il son porte-parole pour la
campagne de 2007 avant que vos rapports
wirth allègre notamment au meeting de
dijon en 2009 où elle s'était invitée
utile de vous rafraîchir la mémoire est
bonne à 7
vous avez alors décidé de prendre un peu
de recul avec une diète médiatique
prolonger royal en 2007 qui pour 2012
vous savez on a on parle énormément des
personnes on va y revenir avec vos
sujets ma préoccupation
c'est que l'ouverture des candidatures
on a décidé une procédure qui n'est
jamais arrivé en france s'appelle les
primaires moi je crois que c'est une
très belle procédure parce que c'est une
extension du suffrage universel on
reproche souvent aux parties de capter
dans le fond les candidatures sont des
petits cénacles qu'ils choisissent pour
les français qui vont présenter
bon donc c'est un problème d'offre
politique là les français en tout cas
les progressistes les français de gauche
vont pouvoir choisir
l'ouverture des candidatures dans ce
qu'on a choisi c'est le 28 juin
attendons de voir qui sera candidat moi
j'ai dit une préférence je souhaiterais
laquelle dominique strauss-kahn puisse
être candidat il apparaît encore je n'en
sais rien je suis pas devin et qu'elle
soit 1 vous le souhaitez je pense que et
je vois mon et je reviens là de trois
jours à strasbourg les inquiétudes que
l'on a non seulement sur la grèce mais
sur le portugal sur l'espagne la
situation économique et sociale
française on vient d'avoir deux réformes
ont en tout cas de débat cette semaine
où vous venez de les mentionner le rsa
avec les propos tout à fait indigents on
va en parler et et la question fiscale
est une question déterminante pour les
grandes réformes dont on a besoin je
crois que dominique strauss kahn peut
être très utile au pays
le début de la semaine commence par une
polémique
c'est lundi et cette polémique vient de
laurent wauquiez qui met les pieds dans
le plat le ministre des affaires
européennes s'en prend aux bénéficiaires
du rsa le revenu de solidarité active
c'est surtout l'assistanat qui est
attaqué ce serait selon le ministre le
cancer de la société
écoutez le révoquer la société française
d'un problème de justice
le problème de justice et le trop peu de
différence entre celui qui travaille et
les minima sociaux voire même parfois
avec des situations absurdes ou en
cumulant différents minima sociaux on
peut se retrouver à gagner plus que
quelqu'un qui travaille au smic
je pense que c'est une vraie question de
justice de rétablir un équilibre là
dessus retrouver un peu de droits et de
devoirs
alors après ces propos la polémique va
s'introduire au sein même du
gouvernement avec une réunion de groupe
musclé mardi matin à l'assemblée
roselyne bachelot ministre en charge du
dossier aurait parlé de beaufitude et de
propos de comptoir hu est alors par
certains députés l'après-midi devant les
caméras l'atmosphère était plus policé
mais quand même pas très clairement
scène cinq heures de travail obligatoire
et plafonnement de la location pour les
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active
une proposition choc du ministre des
affaires européennes qui fait beaucoup
de bruit dans la majorité après les
critiques de roselyne bachelot
le premier ministre a déclaré dès ce
matin devant le groupe ump qu'il fallait
éviter de jeter le discrédit sur les
lois votées par la majorité
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle françois
fillon enfonce le clou
c'est une avancée sociale qui est à
mettre au crédit du président de la
république et cette majorité salle des
quatre colonnes la polémique continue
dans les rangs de l'ump jean leonetti ne
décolère pas de la part d'un membre de
gouvernement dont ce n'est pas la
compétence
dire directement qu'on va faire un
projet de loi plus exactement une
proposition de loi qui est d'origine
parlementaire est de faire en sorte qu
on déstabilise sa majorité
c'est une erreur politique malgré tout
le leader de la droite sociale trouve
quelques soutiens dans un communiqué 22
députés de la majorité dénoncent les
amalgames et les postures d'indignation
suite aux propositions de laurent
wauquiez pour d'autres c'est la forme
qui ne convient pas la question de la
proposition de loi n'est pas adapté je
vous donne mon avis de député il faut
parler de ces sujets là faut tirer les
conséquences des réformes qui ont été
menées faut pourquoi pas après faire des
propositions d'amendements
là où laurent wauquiez a raison c'est
dans l'exigence d'une contrepartie cette
contrepartie est demandée au delà de nos
électeurs elle est demandée par tous les
français en réalité autre soutien celui
de jean-françois copé qui s'est engagé à
étudier les propositions de laurent
wauquiez
dans le cadre de la convention ump sur
la justice sociale le mois prochain
alors laurent wauquiez a été recadrée
par françois fillon puis en conseil des
ministres par nicolas sarkozy il est
monté tout seul au front votre avis je
sais pas si le cynisme va jusqu'à
l'envoyer prendre des coups ce que vous
laissez entendre ce que je constate
c'est quand même deux choses d'abord le
vocabulaire employé
vous mesurez quand même parlé à propos
de gens qui sont dans la difficulté le
cancer de la société française il s'est
disqualifié pour toujours dans des
responsabilités d'homme d'état il parle
au nom de la droite sociale qui soutient
dans ce pays ce genre de discours dans
le même temps l'autre termes employés
justice la justice c'est entre ceux qui
sont au rsa et ceux qui sont au smic
dans le même temps où la même semaine où
le gouvernement qui soutient depuis
quatre ans a fait le bouclier fiscal
envoient des chèques de 100 mille euros
à des gens qui ont des fortunes
colossales et vient encore de favoriser
ce compte plus de 17 millions d'euros
donc voilà on est dans le scandale de la
vie politique française et de cette
majorité est ce que pour faire parler de
soi il faut être prêt à tout c'est
peut-être l'attitude de monsieur voc est
là mais il contribue à ce que moi
j'appelle l'abaissement nationale les
pauvres sont pas les ennemis de la
france et nous avons besoin de créer de
l'emploi et d'avoir aidé exercé une
solidarité à l'égard des indiens ont par
ailleurs il à faux sur le fond parce que
ça compte aussi pas seulement sur la
forme il à faux
le fond le rsa qui se décompose en deux
parties il ya une partie qui est un
socle et puis il ya au contraire ce qui
est prévu quand on reprend une activité
pour qu'il y ait intérêt à reprendre une
activité
donc c'est incroyable c'est absolument
odieux dans la pensée et c'est inexact
dans la forme vincent peillon jean
françois copé a dit que l'assistanat le
rsa serait l'un des curseurs de la
campagne de 2012
est ce que c'est une forme de clivage
qui est en train de naître est ce que
c'est une façon de récupérer des
électeurs selon vous c'est une tactique
politicienne c'est ça que voulait dire
et je crois qu'à un moment où le
national populisme se tient bien on voit
qu'il ya toute une droite dont il fait
partie identité nationale immigration
aux jetons les tunisiens ont aux pauvres
il ya toute une droite qui se dit si on
veut se refaire par rapport à la montée
du front national
il faut alors instrumentaliser un
certain nombre de thèmes et ne pas avoir
peur de le faire quitte à franchir les
frontières du pacte républicain car ce
sont des discours qui pour moi ne sont
pas des discours républicain monsieur
copé dont nous avons eu quand même cette
extraordinaire un président de groupe
qui était en même temps maire qui était
en même temps avocat d'affaires ça n'a
pas beaucoup ému alors il a fini par
démissionner mais il a fallu du temps
pour les uns contiennent pas
incompatibilité avec deux cent mille
euros de revenus d'un an se permet de
donner des leçons aux gens qui sont dans
la difficulté
je trouve que ça va bien et je trouve
d'ailleurs que il y a un défaut
puisqu'il y avait il faut être capables
de s'indigner je suis étonné de voir
l'absence d'indignation sur ces sujets
on s'indigne bien plus souvent de
difficultés de gens qui sont eux mêmes
aux marges de la société que de ces
nantis qui font des loopings
oui si la politique un sondage ont dit
aujourd'hui dit que 67% des français
sont plutôt favorables ce qu'a dit
laurent wauquiez et même une partie des
électeurs de gauche qui serait aussi
favorable
ça vous laisse pas
laisse à réfléchir sur le fond notamment
bah oui sur la déliquescence de l'esprit
public c'est à dire un
il faut dire des horreurs pour qu'on
parle de vous de on ne parle que de vous
cette semaine la cnps de l'assistanat
cette semaine la cour des comptes
explique qu'en france la cour des
comptes a dans l'éducation nationale on
a détruit l'étape post on est en train
d'être totalement régression par rapport
aux autres pays on peut pas faire une
émission sur ce sujet mais monsieur vaud
qui a réussi on va dire est ce que les
peaux sont vraiment les ennemis des
français on ne donne pas les éléments
d'argumentation et voilà c'est comme ça
marche comme ça depuis un certain moment
on voit bien qu'on est dans cette france
qui décline dans cette france qui se
replie sur elle même
dans cette france qui est en train de
mettre des extrémistes de droite aux
avant postes et on a une droite c'est
plus étanche une droite qui est en train
de sortir du cercle républicain le rsa
et par devant le rsa est un est une
mesure prise sous un gouvernement de
droite est ce que si la gauche revient
aux affaires elle le reconduire à tel
quel ou il ya quand même des
aménagements à faire
il ya sans doute des aménagements mais
vous avez raison ça a été fait par la
droite avec d'ailleurs un homme qui
venait de la gauche le parti de
l'ouverture
je crois que l'idée était bonne on avait
le rmi qui au départ il y avait
insertion il ya toujours une idée qui
devait y avoir une contrepartie
mais je vous lis pas ce que ça arrivait
même dans votre métier où la précarité
augmente beaucoup et ça préoccupe vos
syndicats
je souhaite à aucun d'entre vous à aucun
autre vous d'être à un moment dans une
situation vous toucher le rsa j'ai été
très touché par journal libération l'a
bien fait a donné des témoignages les
gens qui sont dans cette situation quand
même les élus les rencontres elles sont
pas des gens qui sont en train de
s'amuser et donc les stigmatiser les
injurier en plus dire qu'ils sont des
gens qui profitent de la société quand
on voit tout ce qui se passe ailleurs
les bonus lui grande rémunération les
endogamie dont je parlais autre
politique ça suffit qu'elle fait quand
même un petit peu évolué on peut le
faire évoluer au départ vous savez ça
partait par expérimentation peut le
faire évoluer on aura à repenser au
mécanisme de solidarité globalement je
vais vous dire et insertion ça n'a pas
forcément très bien fonctionné jusqu'à
présent même s'il
d'un jour comme notre éducation les
sciences mais je pense que si vous
voulez avoir la kz majeur dans cette
affaire c'est qu'il va falloir recréer
la richesse ne pas la gaspiller
or la donne en plus riches et créer de
l'emploi parce que le fond du fond de
cette affaire c'est toujours l'emploi
nous souffrons d'un mal français qui est
le défaut d'emploi et dans la politique
de 2012 nous devons retrouver une
priorité absolue à l'emploi
alors ce vendredi on sait que la la la
la croissance est repartie on parle de
1% pour le premier semestre ce que
justement cette répartition des
richesses parce que ça laisse espérer
cette croissance laisse espérer une
amélioration
il faut le souhaiter mais enfin pour
l'instant on est quand même dans une
grande instabilité donc d'abord il faut
se réjouir de cela mais enfin on n'a pas
encore une tendance lourde est pour
l'instant les tendances qu'on a eu ces
dernières années n'était pas bonne mais
l'objectif doit être évidemment pour la
france de consolider la croissance est
de faire de la croissance
on ne peut pas redistribué sans faire de
la croissance mais il faut aussi nourrir
la croissance de la justice c'est à dire
qu'il faut impliquer tout le monde
par exemple la création d'emplois plutôt
que faire par exemple des heures sup
détaxés ce qui pousse les gens qui ont
déjà un emploi à travailler plus sur le
traitement des autres ça ne fait pas
nécessairement de la croissance donc il
faut bien entendu étayer la croissance
mais il faut le faire aussi par l'emploi
d'abord c'était quand même mieux que nos
voisins européens pour l'instant là sur
ce résultat là en un bon résultat il
faut le confirmer on sait bien qu'on est
très en retard sur l'allemagne sur plein
de points de vue donc il faut pas ça
encore ces politiciens mais moi je me
réjouis si la france fait de la
croissance je suis pas contre maintenant
dire crier victoire là ça n'aurait pas
beaucoup de sens allez on va passer au
mardi avec une journée beaucoup plus
consensuel chez les socialistes
puisqu'on est le dit mr
un concert géant place de la bastille
pour se souvenir des airs de victoire 30
ans après jour pour jour le parti
socialiste fait le sacre de françois
mitterrand opération portes ouvertes au
siège de solférino
c'est un reportage de julie elle sourire
et ambiance bon enfant
en maître de cérémonie martine aubry la
famille mitterrandienne était au grand
complet au siège historique de solférino
et c'est la volonté de rassembler les
français que la première secrétaire du
ps retient d'abord des années me taire
c'est tout l'objectif de cette journée
retrouver l'esprit de françois
mitterrand trouver les réponses
d'aujourd'hui parce que ce ne sont
évidemment pas les mêmes
ne jamais oublier pour qui nous nous
battons pour qui entouré d'une foule de
journalistes et de militants
les anciens ministres pose pour une
photo de famille et déambule au milieu
d'une exposition de unes de presse de
mai 1980
tout en évoquant des souvenirs qu'ils
veulent porteur d'espoir pour la
prochaine présidentielle non des
élections en de 80 on ne donnait pas
forcément françois mitterrand en
vainqueur même si cette 6e était en
train de se préparer et primaire oblige
le prochain leader du ps porte pour
l'instant le simple nom d'espérance
personne ne se risque à prononcer un an
même les tout jeunes militants du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui n'ont évidemment
personne ne peut être ce qu'est françois
mitterrand
mais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont tout
à fait capables d'être
évidemment
tout l'espoir d'un parti socialiste qui
attend encore son leader pendant que
l'ombre de françois mitterrand plane
déjà sur les primaires façon peyo est ce
que le ps n'a pas fait un petit peu trop
avec ces commémorations de françois
mitterrand non il n'avait choisi
d'ailleurs de ne pas en faire beaucoup
il n'a pas fait beaucoup il a fait deux
journées portes ouvertes et cela nous
avertir le soir mais qui était aussi
initié par d'autres un des journaux des
hommes privés et donc au contraire le
choix qui avait été fait qui a été joué
enfin moi je j'ai trouvé qu'il était
intelligent de la part de martine aubry
c'est de ne pas être dans la naphtaline
du souvenir et l'idolâtrie ce n'est pas
du tout l'état d'esprit de cette journée
portes ouvertes est donc de se projeter
aussi dans l'avenir d'être capable de
voir mitterrand mais la gauche parce
qu'on dès le 10 mai c'est la victoire
multi angles c'est la victoire de la
gauche est beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
de gauche avait voté mitterrand qui
n'était pas nécessairement très
mitterrandiste bon donc ça a été fait je
trouve avec les basques de victoire
avant l'heure en 81 la ces
commémorations ou pas du tout moi je te
dis très bonne atmosphère quand tu y vas
y je gagnais nous mais pas du tout moi
je pense et beaucoup de dirigeants
socialistes que nicolas sarkozy n'ait
pas battu
c'est une erreur de le penser il a su
montrer son talent politique les thèmes
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure et
qui sont lancés dans le débat public
sont pas fait par hasard
donc il veut si tu es allé chercher une
certaine france comme il l'a déjà fait
la politique pour lui c'est pas agir et
transformer la vie des gens c'est
acquérir et garder le pouvoir donc moi
je sais pas du tout l'état d'esprit du
parti socialiste en 2012
l'affrontement électorale la bataille
électorale va être extrêmement difficile
et tous ceux qui ont vendu des peau de
l'ours en avoir plus sont toujours plus
c'est une mise en garde pour le parti
socialiste en disant attention c'est pas
l'état d'esprit de martine aubry c'est
pas celui des principaux candidats même
si j'ai été étonné une fois d'entendre
françois hollande venir nicolas sarkozy
déjà battu c'est une erreur absolue
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas battu et la
gauche devrait d'ailleurs faire sans
doute attention a plus parlé aux
français et à davantage se rassemblent
et qu'elle ne le fait en ce moment en
pensant que nicolas sarkozy a commis
tellement de fautes que les choses
seraient déjà fait c'est pas vrai du
tout alors vous avez sûrement vu que
ségolène royal a fait tu es le dit
lui même c'est encore une façon de se
démarquer qui la connaissaient bien non
il ya eu beaucoup d'initiatives et j'ai
trouvé ce qu'elle a fait qu'ils étaient
sur le thème républicain absolument je
fais est utile et quand elle lit il ne
faut pas abandonner la nation aux
extrémistes elle a tout à fait raison
on se souvient pendant la campagne à
propos du drapeau elle voulait en 2007
un drapeau bleu blanc rouge dans chaque
famille avec le recul vous trouvez qu'il
y avait un petit côté un peu
grandiloquent républicain parfois moi
j'ai surtout je me souviens et je pense
qu'on devrait en tirer quelques
conclusions le souvenir de quelqu'un qui
a affirmé la france métissée une france
qui devient aujourd'hui raciste qui ne
peut pas se voir tel quel et qui ne
comprend pas ce que sont la diversité
des populations en particulier les
jeunes sur son territoire j'ai le
souvenir d'un grand discours à vitrolles
où la république et c'est effectivement
les principes mêmes de la république
s'est pas demander aux gens d'où ils
viennent mais où ils veulent aller
ensemble c'est le principe même de la
révolution française et donc je garde
surtout cette idée d'ailleurs jean
pierre chevènement était à nos côtés
dans la campagne moi même j'aime
passionnément la république qu'elle a su
tenir des discours républicain que la
gauche ne doit jamais oublier qu'elle a
aussi à relever cet étendard la santé
vous étiez cette semaine à strasbourg
mais la polémique sur la porsche de
neige strauss kahn n'a pas pu vous
échapper sa mort le poète l on en a même
beaucoup parler dans la presse
européenne me semble-t-il erreur grave
erreur grave maladresses de
communication
non je crois d'abord je crois pas que la
communication doit faire la politique
alors tous les commentaires participent
elle y participe mais c'est j'écris un
livre entier cette année dont on ne
parle pas encore mais pour expliquer
justement que c'est la mort du politique
on peut y venir c'est arrivé dans
d'autres époques si on pense que
l'habillage remplace la politique vous
mangez vos enfants vont à l'école où
vous soigner ça c'est la politique
l'urbanisme si c'est uniquement l'image
la porsche le monde donc moi je crois
que cet épisode qui est vu d'ailleurs
par nos partenaires européens avec plus
d'humour qui cite entendu ils regardent
y compris les réactions français cette
espèce bon alors évidemment dominique
strauss kahn comprend qu'il va être
l'objet de toutes les attentions c'est
une bonne chose
je crois que ce qu'on doit attendre un
candidat à la présidentielle c'est
qu'ils nous parlent politique
et donc ils nous disent comment
effectivement va refaire de la
croissance comment on va casser ces
ghettos urbains comme on va faire
l'école française une école qui
fonctionne et que nous attendons avec
impatience
ou plutôt ces éléments là avec les
français jugeront dominique strauss kahn
là dessus plutôt que oui mais vous
conviendrez qu'il vaut mieux parler de
ça loin d'une porsche que près d'une
porsche avait je sais que ça gêne mais
celui cet ami qui conduisait la porsche
n'est pas née nantis avancer les
qualifications c'est possible c'est un
garçon je né dans une banlieue c'est un
garçon qui est français mais qui est de
libération le monde
et alors c'est possible et moi je m'en
réjouis assez je suis très étonné de
voir une certaine france parce que c'est
pas dans les milieux ouvriers que j'ai
entendu les reproches c'est dans une
certaine france très bourgeoise très cul
serré qui veut garder les choses pour
elle et qui en même temps là à le
complexe de quelque chose qu'elle n'aime
pas y compris une façon d'afficher ce
que l'on vient de gagner donc moi je
trouve que là on est très loin de
l'essentiel qui a aussi des relents bon
voilà certains peuvent dire une
maladresse je l' ai vu pourquoi pas pour
les communicants moi je suis tout sauf
un communicant dont je peux pas juger ça
mais par contre j'attends avec
impatience qu'on parle politique près
les mardis encore c'est la mauvaise
surprise pour christine lagarde le
procureur général jean louis nadal
demande à la cour de justice de la
république d'ouvrir contre la ministre
de l'économie
une enquête pour abus d'autorité dans la
sphère du crédit lyonnais
la procédure d'arbitrage en 2008 avait
donné lieu au versement de plus de 200
millions d'euros à bernard tapie
réactions dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée oui on peut dire que c'est
une victoire donc plus qu'à une
satisfaction que l'état lui-même accepte
une procédure d'arbitrage s'était déjà
suspect
le résultat lui-même était extravagant
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya
derrière potentiellement c'est vrai une
interrogation sur les 800 une affaire
d'état et ce n'est guère dit une femme
particulièrement honnête je la connais
depuis longtemps
je suis quand même assez dubitatif
devant
tout d'un coup se réveille trois ans
après peut-être plus
pourquoi pas avant et trois ans après on
arrive quoi que les élections
présidentielles est soupçonné rien une
petite affaire préélectorale petites
affaires électorales ou en quête de show
je souhaite pas que la campagne
présidentielle se fasse sur tout ce qui
n'est pas politique les acteurs les
voitures les parce qu'on peut encore
passer à côté de notre destin collectif
deuxièmement plus aura de transparence
mieux ce sera donc il faut pas non plus
empêcher ces procédures normales alors
mardi encore les députés examinent une
proposition de loi ump sur
l'installation du gaz de schiste
longueur a pu être consensuel mais
socialistes et écologistes se sont
finalement opposé à la majorité sur ce
texte jugé pas assez contraignant le
dossier en tout cas a provoqué une
rencontre écologistes inédite devant
l'assemblée nationale
jérémy arc battre nicolas hulot et eva
joly pour la première fois côte à côte
dans la rue au moins le combat contre le
gaz de schiste ne fracture pas les
écologistes ils les rassemblent
il y aura de toutes façons de contrainte
physique à laquelle on a prêché à
laisser la parole
orientons nos investissements orientons
la technologie orientons les
comportements en fonction des impératifs
de castet chez c'est une technologie de
siècle dernier elle le souhaitant
rentrer réellement dans le 21e siècle
avec les énergies renouvelables les
leaders écologistes unanime et tous
présents devant l'assemblée nationale
pour dénoncer une proposition de loi
vidé de sa substance selon eux si la
première version du texte retirait aux
industriels
toutes les autorisations pour exploiter
le gaz de schiste la dernière mouture
débattue ce soir dans l'hémicycle leur
laisse finalement la possibilité
d'explorer les sous sol français à une
condition que ces groupes pétrochimiques
trouve d'ici deux mois des méthodes
moins polluante que la fracturation
hydraulique totalement quand total dit
nous avons des techniques alternatives
total n'a jamais forés n'a jamais été
chercher des gaz et huiles de schiste
aujourd'hui croire le discours de total
c'est effectivement c'est de la poudre
aux yeux
c'est de l'enfumage les socialistes qui
se sont finalement rangés derrière la
position des écologistes
après avoir un temps envisagé de voter
le texte proposé par l'ump christian
jacob
si le ps déclare aujourd'hui qu'ils
votent compte ce qu'ils ont voté la
semaine dernière et entre autres sur des
amendements qu'ils ont eux même déposé
c'est à dire qu'ils vont aller voter
contre les amendements qu'ils ont
déposées c'est un peu compliqué à
expliquer ces explications les
socialistes ont commencé à les donner ce
soir dans l'hémicycle
la proposition de loi est examiné en
procédure accélérée le vote devrait
avoir lieu dès demain soir vincent
peillon on entendu là christian jacob
les socialistes ont d'abord travaillé
avec le mp sur un texte commun puis
finalement rejoint les écologistes pour
réclamer une interdiction totale s'était
pas un peu brouillon pour un dossier
aussi important
vous avez raison mais tout a été
brouillon dans cette affaire un depuis
le début est d'abord au départ il y
avait aussi deux propositions puissent
ont dit on va les réunir
et puis
ces problèmes les rapports de force
l'ump ne veut pas exactement ce que veut
le parti socialiste donc à essayer de
passer en force donc on arrive à cette
situation
plus globalement vous avez vu et
politiques ont découvert assez
tardivement le gaz de schiste et
difficulté c'est monté j'ai des dangers
il ya eu ces événements aux états unis
ce film et il ya eu certaines
associations qui sont mobilisés bon très
bien moi c'est dans ma région donc j'ai
vu l'ardèche et le gard j'ai vu mon
sushi là ça quand même
à mon avis la sphère est réglé un donc
vous faites pas de souci pour le gaz de
schiste dans les temps qui viennent à
mon avis la pression des partis les
populations s'allier dans une belle
unanimité l'ump sur surnom précisément
non mais derrière vous allez voir que la
pression aujourd'hui moi je me suis
promené sur les sites j'y suis allé les
populations et à dire quand on voit les
dégâts que ça peut causer ces faits sans
précautions suffisantes
bon mais nous avons un problème ce qui a
été dit d'ailleurs qui est quand même le
problème majeur sortait du gaz de
schiste que vous avez découvert ya un
mois et donc n'est pas une grande
spécialiste c'est le problème de la
politique énergétique
on peut pas dire c'est la fin du pétrole
on veut sortir du nucléaire on ne veut
pas du gaz de schiste on veut pas le
retour au charbon bon alors on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça c'était aux
membres je vois à peu près ce qu'on fait
mais c'est un des très beaux débats de
la présidentielle très important pour
nous tous de trouver la politique
énergétique pour la france pour les
temps qui viennent et 30 40 50 années
qui viennent et le faire aussi vieille
de jacques delors dans un cadre européen
parce que dans cette affaire aussi nous
avons une question qui n'est pas rien
qui la souveraineté nationale c'est la
capacité à la suffisance que nous avons
à satisfaire nos besoins énergétiques
donc nous avons devant nous un très
grand débat le gaz de schiste pas mon
avis un peu disparaître dans ce débat
mais noah nous avons des éléments
importants les esprits ont évolué sur le
nucléaire français je le vois il va
falloir en sortir
à quel rythme comment en investissant
sur quelles technologies donc le solaire
l'éolienne toutes les énergies
renouvelables sûr et sans doute aussi
aussi d'autres recherchent encore on a
quand même encore nos problèmes de
gestion de déchets donc à beaucoup de
choses à mercredi on va passer à tout
autre chose on a parlé de l'impôt sur la
fortune qui est en passe d'être réformé
ce mercredi donc le conseil des
ministres examine la réforme de la
fiscalité du patrimoine nicolas sarkozy
en perd 1,6 qui fut l'un des projets
phares de son quinquennat le bouclier
fiscal supprimé
en contrepartie l'impôt sur la fortune
est allégé explications de chloé buffard
françois baroin au pas de charge
dernière ligne droite pour la réforme de
la fiscalité du patrimoine en fin de
matinée audition du ministre du budget
par la commission des finances
le bouclier fiscal est supprimé dès 2012
c'est la fin d'un des symboles de la
rupture voulue par nicolas sarkozy en
il n'était pas concevable de supprimer
le bouclier sans toucher à l'iesf il
devenait logique et équilibrée en
supprimant le bouclier d'en modifier ses
effets aujourd'hui trop négatif l'impôt
sur la fortune est maintenu mais dans
une version allégée il faudra posséder
un patrimoine de plus d'un point 3
million d'euros contre 800 mille euros
actuellement pour être assujettis à l
isf
autre changement il n'y aura plus que
deux tranches et deux taux d'imposition
contre six aujourd'hui coût de la
réforme 1,7 milliard d'euros le
gouvernement s'est engagé à compenser à
l'euro près première source la
suppression du bouclier fiscal qui
devrait rapporter 800 millions d'euros
pour le reste le gouvernement table sur
un alourdissement de la fiscalité sur
les donations et les successions ainsi
que sur une taxe sur les exilés fiscaux
la réforme de l'isf telle qu'elle nous
est présenté aujourd'hui n'est pas
financé et pour parvenir à cela il
faudra donc que la france s'endette
le gouvernement entend faire adopter le
texte très rapidement avant le 14
juillet pour une entrée en vigueur dès
2012 alors suppression du bouclier
fiscal hausse des taxations sur les gros
héritages a quand même quelques bonnes
mesure selon vos noces cette réforme non
plus une politique d'abord de gribouille
qui doit quand même vraiment inquiéter
nos concitoyens de voir que des gens qui
ont soutenu avec force la qualité de ses
réformes pendant des années tout d'un
coup 10 à poser un problème est quand
même un problème de crédibilité de la
parole politique de la part de la droite
de gouvernement mais c'est affligeant
parce que ça nous a coûté très cher donc
ces dernières années ces mesures
fiscales qui avait d'ailleurs commencé
jean françois copé avait fait le premier
bouclier fiscal assez tôt et qui est
toujours d'ailleurs fondé sur un
mensonge faire croire qu'en france ce
sont les riches qui payent le plus
d'impôts alors qu'on est un pays la
courbe du conduit encore de le dire et
moins redistributif autrement dit en
france quand vous êtes au smic vous
prisé presque 50% d'impôt pour les uns
pas exactement
et quand vous êtes madame bettencourt
comme on l'a vu ces 6 % c'est quand même
on marche sur la tête et ces gens là ont
fait toutes les campagnes en dix ans les
pauvres riches alors on attaque comme le
fait les pauvres les gens qui sont au
rsa
mais dans cette affairé à une
manipulation car en réalité ceux qui
vont le plus bénéficié je supprime le
bouclier fiscal mais j'allège l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune
et dans cet allégement de l'impôt sur de
solidarité sur la fortune sont les plus
grandes fortunes
on voyait les chiffres qu'ils étaient
maintenant mais de notoriété est
reconnue partout ce sont les plus
grandes fortunes qui vont encore être
favorisé le milliard sept certains
disent que c'est un peu plus simple et
si vous revenez au pouvoir ce que vous
faites de la peau sur la fortune je
pense qu'il faudra revoir les choses on
a un énorme problème si vous voulez on
est des pays où lorsque vous travaillez
vous êtes durement taxes et lorsque vous
êtes rentiers ou capitaliste vous l'êtes
beaucoup moins donc déjà il faudra
harmoniser cette fiscalité
c'est une chose qui est absolument
essentiel deuxièmement aujourd'hui même
si vous travaillez et que vous
travaillez à un certain niveau catégorie
supérieure vous ne pouvez plus acquérir
du capital et y compris pour vous loger
et quand on regarde pour les jeunes
générations qui arrivent suffit plus de
faire de bonnes études ça ne permet pas
de monnayer un appartement à paris ou
dans des centres villes donc c'est
l'héritage qui prend à nouveau le dessus
donc il va falloir la fois traiter ce
problème celui de la fiscalité du
travail et cette grande réforme fiscale
qu'on proposait depuis des années qui
maintenant celle que la gauche portent
unanimement qui consiste à fondre
l'impôt sur le revenu la csg faire
havrais pour progresser la peau à
nicolas sarkozy quand même évoque cette
semaine une taxe sur les sur les hauts
salaires et sur les
les bonus on ne sait pas encore sous
quelle forme il ya quand même la volonté
affichée publiquement de s'en prendre
aux revenus
il ya le mensonge de plus si vous avez
compris qu'il est en campagne électorale
il avait exactement le contraire pendant
quatre ans oui mais nous on a fait quand
même quelques réformes dans ce pays
heureusement un de la tension tht
ralisation la suppression de la peine de
mort le rmi dont on parlait la csg tous
assez sociale donc sur les boeufs la
priorité à l'éducation chaque fois qu'il
ya eu un progrès toutes les régressions
c'est ça c'est la loi du mensonge qui
passe donc vous allez avoir une année où
effectivement à nouveau une prime de
1000 euros pour les salariés vous a vu
qu'il n'a pas un car qui la touche rond
cette prime mais ses déclarations c'est
à la télévision on y croit et derrière
on fait le contraire
moi je vous dis qu'il n'y aura pas de
mise en oeuvre de cette taxation des
hauts revenus il a fait exactement le
contraire pendant quatre ans mais il va
vendre de la poudre de perlimpinpin
comme il l'avait en 2007
mercredi un scénario irréaliste en
commission au sénat le projet de loi sur
les soins psychiatriques connaît de
multiples rebondissements le rapporteur
centriste a décidé de jeter l'épongé
en cause un amendement phare et très
polémiques l'obligation pour les
médecins de soigner les malades à
domicile et plus seulement dans les
hôpitaux explication de cet imbroglio
parlementaire avec élise aicardi devant
le sénat la fronde des psychiatres et
des soignants et dans les murs de la
haute assemblée à la commission des
affaires sociales il souffle un vent de
révolte
la semaine dernière la commission a tout
simplement rejeté le texte
une première pour une commission la
rapporteure muguette dini désavoué à
démissionner elle est remplacée par un
ump jean-louis lorrain un peu dépassé
par les événements on peu surréaliste
voulait donc en lien avec la psychiatrie
car la commission qui continue sa lutte
à voter tous les amendements extérieur
même ceux de l'opposition et même celui
qui demande le retrait pur et simple du
texte
l'après midi la séance commence donc
dans l'incertitude totale
on est dans le cas de m
institution où c'est le texte de la
commission qui est discuté en séance
donc le texte du rapporteur qui est le
texte de la commission qui n'est pas
d'accepter
comment fait-on on est en train de faire
la première expérience ce texte porte
tous les attributs des lois émotionnel
des loi d'affichage il laisse de côté
toutes les questions qu'un vrai projet
de loi sur la psychiatrie la santé
mentale aurait dû aborder
je trouve à la hauteur la façon dont
vous caricaturez ce texte alors que nous
proposons une alternative à
l'enfermement
alors que nous avons une attention
particulière pour les patients pour les
remettre en liberté et non plus
uniquement les enfermer après la
discussion générale
place aux votes des motions de rejet du
texte pour l'adoption 149 contre 185
le sénat n'a pas adopté la motion de
rejet n'est donc pas adoptée la ministre
peut effectivement souffler le débat
continue mais le texte a déjà marqué
durablement les esprits au sénat vincent
peillon c'est un texte très important ce
texte soit la psychiatrie est ce que
pour vous ça pourrait être d'ailleurs un
peu être un sujet de philosophie pour le
bac peut-on imposer de soigner par la
loi donc soutenu par la loi c'est
certainement pas je vais vous dire la
vérité je n'ai pas suivi dans le détail
ce sont vraiment des sujets qu'il faut
traiter je suis à s'effondrer de ce que
je découvre l'amour était très dure
semaine sur des sujets bien les sujets
de soins publics qui devraient quand
même normalement puis le sénat dans sa
sagesse comme on dit transcender les
clivages partisans dans une démocratie
apaisée
donc là c'est pas le cas une si petite
victoire on peut se dire je suis passé à
181 contre 140 c'est pas bon sur des
sujets question comme ça donc je n'ai
pas de jugement très précis
sur ce qui est en question je réponds
non à votre question quand même ça très
précisément mais je vois que ça a été
très malmené ajustements le 25 septembre
prochain ce sont les élections
sénatoriales on connaît enfin la date
cette semaine si la gauche revient au
pouvoir est ce que vous imaginez pouvoir
l'emporter au sénat le 25 septembre je
suis pas du tout un spécialiste ça m'est
reproché est complet pour moi même des
questions électorales depuis longtemps
mais il semblerait que pourquoi il n'y
aurait pas une alternance au sénat comme
il y en a eu partout ailleurs c'est sain
pour la démocratie donc ça serait une
bonne chose ça y est tenté par un poste
de sénateur dans votre carrière vous
dites vous même que c'est ça devrait
être la politique de la sérénité qui
concerne les gens c'est parce que je
suis dans mon action de parlementaires
européens mais mais pourquoi pas s'est
fait un nom c'est pas pourquoi pas c'est
vraiment pas d'actualité mais je ne
préjuge pas comme je compte vivre très
vieux très âgées avoir une très longue
carrière politique je ne sais pas ce que
je ferai des sénateurs très vieux mais
je ne disais pas ça mais moi j'ai pas
faire passer l'orage et donc sera payant
je serai peut-être un jour conseiller
général-maire même voyez enfin ne sais
pas ce sont des choses qui arrivent en
tête je vais arrêter la politique de
main allez on va passer au g20 on va
passer au jeudi quand christine ockrent
refait de la télévision
ce jeudi matin christine ockrent est
auditionné par une mission d'information
sur les dysfonctionnements de
l'audiovisuel extérieur de la france qui
chapeaute france 24 rfi et tv5 monde
climat de guerre interne mauvaise
gestion plans sociaux l'audition qui est
retransmise en direct par les chaînes
parlementaires a parfois ce jour là des
allures de tribunal on écoute n'est pas
question que je démissionne démissionner
pour donner raison à tous ceux qui ont
exploité de façon honteuse cette affaire
d'espionnage informatique en souillant
mon honneur ma réputation donner crédit
à toutes ces insinuations démissionné
pour leur donner raison non le sentiment
de malaise parce que vous vous présentez
effectivement comme une victime mais ce
qui nous intéresse ou que c'est
l'intérêt de la chaîne et le conflit que
vous nous décrivez à loisir aujourd'hui
excusez moi mais ils m'intéressent
beaucoup moins que l'avenir de la chaîne
la situation aujourd'hui est devenu
tellement surréaliste qu'elle est
incompréhensible
voilà deux dirigeants qui sont les plus
hauts salaires de l'audiovisuel français
publics qui se font la guerre par
tribunaux interposés avec une violence
tout de même exceptionnel et l'état est
en train d'annoncer qu'il va engager un
deuxième plan social elle a vu comment
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que les
salariés de l'aef devant ce spectacle
puisse rester serein ce conflit de à la
tête de l'exécutif porte préjudice
aussi au-delà des personnes et j'ai
d'abord parler d'elle mais portent
préjudice à l'entreprise à ses
personnels et donc quelque part à
l'image de la france à l'extérieur
vous le voyez un des interpellations
très durs à l'égard de la directrice
délégué général pour rebondir sur ce que
dit monsieur herbillon donc être député
européen
c'est dommage de voir comme ça l'image
de la france aussi brouillé c'est le
problème des nominations politiques
moi je n'ai pas commenter ce qui
concerne les chaînes de télévision même
si j'ai eu à m'exprimer autrefois sur la
courtisanerie de certains qui organisé
sur le service public des débats qu'on
faisait en préfecture sur l'identité
nationale l'immigration mais je me
souviens des nominations des deux
personnes qui s'affrontent aujourd'hui
sont des nominations trop politique par
rapport à des médias qui devrait être
indépendant et on va dans un sens qui
dans le fond on le dit est de plus en
plus ce christine ockrent c'était une
nomination politique parce qu'on n'est
pas recette on dit de l'ancien café d'en
faire une haie du ministre des affaires
étrangères qui était sur marie c'est
dans toute la presse et s'est avéré
depuis longtemps je trouve que la france
de temps en temps devrait se moderniser
et empruntés à la culture libérale un
peu de transparence et de séparation des
pouvoirs
ce serait bon pour votre métier comme on
a besoin d'un espace public et d'un
esprit public qui se revigore votre
métier l'information de ce pont du las
est essentielle il faut faire attention
à la fois à la commande privée
on l'a les grands groupes qui sont entre
les mains de grands groupes financiers
qui vivent aussi la commande publique on
n'a toujours pas réglé ce problème
et deuxièmement je ne suis pas pour que
les politiques j'en fais partie et la
mainmise sur un certain nombre de médias
mais pour reprendre les propos de député
la voix de la france vous qui êtes
député européen est ce qu'elle est
vraiment entendu est ce qu'on a cette
chaîne france 24 qui porte la voix de la
france est ce que pour vous elle est
suffisante en ut appelé où elle est
appelée à se développer et sa moc
aujourd'hui il manque d'une voix de la
france a bien sûr enfin vous savez c'est
un groupe maintenant par exemple radio
france internationale sur lequel j'ai
entendu des tas de moqueries d'un groupe
et avec les journalistes qui sont
écoutés et
et écoutez évidemment tout à fait à
l'extérieur de nos frontières donc à la
des journalistes compétents
on peut d'ailleurs nous mêmes vous savez
je voyais un article de gens le vrai
travail qui se passe les français sont
les moins présents au parlement européen
même quand il est en france à strasbourg
les grands médias tous les médias
étrangers sont là quand on veut parler
d'un sujet par exemple quand j'étais le
rapporteur l'union pour la méditerranée
c'est pas rien surtout pour les français
qui sont quand même sur la rive sud sur
la rive nord de la méditerranée mais
auprès de la méditerranée c'est rfi qui
fait le boulot qui a de bons
journalistes qui c'est qui interroge qui
suit ses dossiers etc et donc je trouve
que nous avons besoin d'un pôle
évidemment international je suis pas sûr
je le dis même si je crois que ça se
développe et c'est après à se développer
que certaines décisions qui ont été
prises au début on favoriser au mieux le
développement
alors si vous revenez au pouvoir encore
une fois c'est la question qu'est ce que
vous faites est ce que vous comment vous
nommer des présidents des différentes
chaînes et notamment pour france 24 pour
un ré fille et pour toutes les autres
chaînes qui ont besoin d'un président
moi je crois maintenant qu'on a besoin à
la fois de procédure parlementaire
associant des majorités les oppositions
et c est qu on a en même temps besoin de
commission indépendante de gens du
métier et qui peuvent s'accompagner de
gens d'autres métiers mais qui ne sont
pas des politiques ça existe dans
beaucoup de pays les commissions
déontologie les commissions de
nomination et de ce point de vue là je
souhaite vraiment un et c'est impératif
parce que il faudra une césure en 2010
en 2012 il faudra dire oui il ya eu un
abaissement national
il faut une refondation républicaine
indépendance de la justice
attention à la police à parlement qui
peut exercer ses droits et il va falloir
un grand plan pour l'indépendance des
médias et c'est pas seulement le csa qui
peut être à l'origine c'est tel qu'il
est constitué tels que sont nommés c'est
mon jeu que je pense qu'il appelle à
quelques réformes donc une refonte du
csa s'est positionné verbe bien sûr et
qui sont d'ailleurs dans le projet du
parti socialiste
il va falloir évoluer sur ces sujets et
on est plutôt en train de régresser
vous aimez le cinéma sont payants moi
j'aime beaucoup le cinéma je suis né
dans un cinéma mais j'ai peu de temps
pour y aller nous promener dans un
cinéma s'il est majeur suivi le plus
vieux de france qui était gérée pas ma
grand mère qui était président des
cinémas d'art et d'essai
j'ai passé ma vie dans les cabines de
cinéma un vivre avec le bruit du cinéma
voilà vous devez sûrement suivre aussi
le festival de cannes est un film et
sera projeté la semaine prochaine hors
compétition un film qui retrace
l'arrivée de nicolas sarkozy au pouvoir
ça s'appelle la conquête c'est denis
podalydès qui joue le rôle de nicolas
sarkozy regardez cet extrait on s'y
croirait si aulas si pour toi ça regarde
ça bien sûr qu'à toi et regarde chez moi
cet accord bino du c'est tous ces gens
là qu'est ce qu'il faut que l'argent
n'est marqué vers les mois à venir moi
tous ces gens qui n'ont rien fait merci
monsieur
je sais qui
alors je regarde où joue qu'à
l'enseignement rien personne dernier
je sais qui
je les garde pour
je veux être le président d'une
république irréprochable
vincent père vous allez allez le voir ce
film je crois pas pourquoi nous sommes
intéressés par et gérez vous dire c'est
que je crois que bon moi je connais
celui qui a fait le scénario d'un très
bon acteur là mais en voyant ça vraiment
je pense à une chose
moi j'étais le premier j'ai jamais
hésiter je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se retourne à considérer que ce
que faisait nicolas sarkozy était une
blessure pour la république française
mais les attaques contre l'homme la
normalité la taille l'hystérie etc
je veux pas d'une campagne
présidentielle là dessus c'est une carie
me dit ça ça fera le lit des extrémistes
on a connu d'autres époques et je
souhaite que la gauche la droite elle
aura sa responsabilité est là aussi je
souhaite que la gauche fasse une
campagne sur des arguments sur le fond
sur les bilans sur les propositions pas
sur les personnes et pas sur les
caractères et pas sur les images se
serait ce qui pourrait nous arriver de
pire voulait dire que ce film est une
attaque volontaire une caricature
neuvien été jeunes anciens je viens
juste de regarder ce passage où cette
année on était quand même sur la taille
on avait un personnage qui semblait un
peu agités qui disait des grossièretés
alors on dit que ça correspond j'ai vu
beaucoup de journalistes qu'il racontait
ça moi je suis un responsable politique
et je pense que nous ne devons pas faire
de la politique comme ça moi je n'en
ferai pas et ça m'a fait penser à ce que
je vous ai dit faisons bien attention
car je vois des tentations faisons bien
attention à ce que cette campagne
présidentielle se soit un bilan contre
aussi le bilan qu'on avait avant 2002 et
un projet contre un projet il ya aussi
carla bruni qui est un film de woody
allen
cette semaine là aussi on est dans la
confusion des genres je ne suis pas je
veux pas des jeux veut pas non plus dire
je n'irai plus au cinéma parce que les
sarkozystes les écrans helvétique
mais en tout cas écouté mon fils de
douze heures est allé le voir avant-hier
puisqu'il sortait à paris et j'ai dîné
avec lui hier il m'a dit qu'il trouvait
ça très joli
voilà bien joué que projeté il m'a pas
parlé d'elle
ce retour en arrière ce pari historique
cette deuxième histoire d'amour par là
même un petit garçon a trouvé ça très
joli essai j'ai un moment j'aimerais
voir ce nom mais je vous jure que je
crois que
il me semble que c'est pas l'essentiel
du film de woody et que c'est une petite
déformation de penser qu'il faut
conduire uniquement sur carla bruni
parce que vous avez un politique en
phase ii au delà tout ça c'est la
peopolisation de la vie politique que
vous condamnez c'est ça non c'est pire
que ça ça c'est la tentation néo
populistes et fasciste qui est déjà
arrivé dans l'histoire de l'europe au
xxème siècle qui consiste à penser au
bout d'un moment que la politique c'est
des questions d'image des questions
d'appartenance des questions de
caractère alors qu'en réalité je
continue de croire que c'est
l'indépendance des médias l'école le
progrès la santé etc et que j'aimerais
qu'on parle de ça et que attaquer les
adversaires sur par exemple des
questions physiques me semble quand même
vraiment on parle d'autorité
d'exemplarité imaginer comme j'espère
que c'est pas ce que vous dites à vos
enfants d'abord il faut attaquer l'autre
parce qu'il est petit gros je n'irai pas
voir le film
en tout cas vous me direz pas voir ce
film non puis c'est vrai que par
ailleurs bon sarkozy n'a pas besoin en
plus d'aller au cinéma
allez on va terminer avec une pensée
pour les journalistes hervé ghesquière
et stéphane taponier ainsi que leurs
trois accompagnateurs
c'était ce vendredi leur 500e jour de
captivité avec des manifestations de
soutien un peu partout en france
ici à paris avec le comité de soutien et
l'association reporters sans frontières
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci vincent peillon s'est arrêté avec
nous quant à nouveau dès la semaine
prochaine